foreign
[Music]
Star Wars project you need to do it with
the right color and angle that color is
mustard yellow and that angle is toward
the stars that are apparently at War
also also former Jedi Knight I'm no Star
Wars encyclopedia but even I can hear
the frustrated Cries From outraged
forums saying that Ahsoka left the Jedi
Order before officially becoming a Jedi
Knight contradicting your own Cannon
before a word of dialogue is spoken is
quite impressive even for Star Wars also
episode 3 Revenge of the also a secret
map you say a secret map to find a
powerful figure who hasn't been seen in
years you say I don't know everyone sure
is Awakening something familiar in me
these Republic uniforms tell me that the
in-universe team that designs them is
either hugely underpaid or hugely
doesn't give a sh I'm calling it Bluff
signal them to come aboard if you don't
think they're Jedi why would you allow
them on your ship you have projector
communication systems that let you see
them use one of those letting them on
your ship just opens you up to attack or
dare I say a trap looks like we finally
haven't answered why these helmets look
so ridiculous it appears to be the
result of a budget cutting
one-size-fits-all situation the Republic
can't afford to make a helmet for every
species so they just pick the widest
head and went with that the bad guys
have already been found out but even if
they hadn't their arrival method really
didn't do them any favors not only do
they arrive in what looks like an
imperial shuttle and a bad disguise but
they also disembark accompanied by a
dramatic smoke machine to properly
accentuate their evilness you're no Jedi
just some overconfident Imperial trash
who just pushed their luck too far he's
got some stiff competition but this
might be the worst captain in the
Republic he knew he knew two weren't who
they said they were and still managed to
get completely caught off guard that the
Republic defeat the Empire and then
immediately set all systems to
complacent the Vader hallway scene is
legendary because it's dark and he
suddenly appears destroying all in his
path but this scene works for the exact
opposite reason it's well lit you can
see bailin coming and there's still
nothing you can do to stop him we see
you Ray rest in peace raylen you are
true to your word I'm well paid for it
lady Morgan wait she seems familiar okay
back to the internet
huh looks like she popped up in Mando
season two wait season two how do you
expect me to remember a character I last
saw three whole years ago who is this
Jedi Ahsoka roll title card
okay admittedly that was forcing badass
but I hope you didn't just land on the
thing you came here to find we all love
a good archaeological puzzle but I'm
pretty sure Soca Jones here is using the
force to figure this out and forgive me
if listening to vague voices in someone
else's head isn't quite as exciting as
an invisible Bridge
stealthy assassin droids with loud
Flappy capes there sure are a lot of
weapons out there that negate the
advantages of lightsabers aren't there
but why do we only ever see the bad guys
using them why doesn't anyone in the
Rebellion or New Republic use stuff like
this especially when all you need to
make your weapon lightsaber proof is
some kind of crackling laser oh yeah
where are you
and she didn't hear him getting close
what good is the force if you can't use
it to censor even hear a giant ass
spaceship arriving
all right he's you said to self-destruct
on these Droids to Oppenheimer I know
there are three of them but by qui-gon's
beard this is a huge ass explosion watch
my back that is
which I am not Padawan literally means
learner so sticking that word on the end
is redundant it's the chai tea thing all
over again also anyone can watch
ahsoka's back it doesn't have to be a
Padawan but we're clearly more invested
in trying to Parent Trap ahsokin Sabine
how did you get her to tell the truth
let's just say I didn't follow standard
Jedi protocol torture euphemisms in
Disney products the location of the last
missing Imperial Grand Admiral that's
possible thrawn died at the Battle of
the Fall believing this in a universe
that brought back a bifurcated Darth
Maul by giving him Robo legs if thrawn
survived does that mean Esther
so elsbeth was buddies with thrawn and
somehow found out this map in a tomb
would guide her to his location despite
the rest of the Galaxy believing he's
dead okay fine maybe she knows something
we don't but what does this have to do
with her buddy Ezra still being alive
also who the is Ezra stop leaving
me out I already feel guilty for not
watching all of Clone Wars and Rebels
you don't need to keep wailing on me
with references I don't get nothing
except our enemies believe that they
know where to look that's a very
reassuring way of saying it doesn't
matter that this nonsense is nonsense
because the fact that our enemies
believe it isn't nonsense means that it
is isn't nonsense the device is locked
is you activating it has a limited meme
you know who can help you with this
ahsoka's mission is at a dead end and of
course the one person who can help her
isn't a strange figure from her past
hooray for a ready big drama laced
reluctant team-ups I guess I'm not sure
she'll want to help believing that
someone wouldn't want to save an old
friend and prevent the return of an evil
Galactic superpower because of that one
time you wouldn't let them play Jedi
anymore
we dedicate here today stands in
recognition
of Commander Bridger and the rebel
leaders monuments to war heroes that are
more worried about being a
self-referential nod to a cartoon than
actually war hero monumenting Sabine
Wren
now hero is too cool for your hero
worship and would rather be off racing
something at dangerous speeds instead of
being celebrated as a hero cliche also
close this is a long ass completely
trafficless Highway did the whole world
know she needed some free road to be
mopey on her moped she's crazy
this done is apparently enough to
justify this officer going from all
right look Commander I have my orders
I'm gonna need you to pull over two I
guess because he respects her right to
recklessly endanger herself and one of
his colleagues showing us the entirety
of this giraffe spotted flamingo-legged
cat things dinner routine
Hollow skip we're not really family
but you're like a sister to me Dave
filoni trying in futility to put an end
to all the Sabine Ezra shippers out
there either the Jedi has the map
or it was vaporized great point which
makes me even more curious as to why you
set your droids to nuclear Holocaust if
keeping the map intact was the ultimate
goal luck has nothing to do with it Fate
has decided our next moon semantics we
were missed Sabine everyone was there
not everyone expecting president Clancy
to be able to summon the dead and make
them attend their own memorials I think
I know how to find Ezra dot dot dot if
he's alive right you see that part is
really important unless you
enjoy being in the building false hope
game where did you find this in a world
named Arcana
it was a stronghold for the witches of
dothamir Arcana witches this is where
Star Wars confuses the can Anatomy okay
maybe they're just reaching for the
closest English translation but it's so
distracting when Concepts that are
embedded in Earth mythology somehow end
up being used a long time ago in a
galaxy supposedly far far away I take it
these patterns of meanings
you have the artist guy tell me what you
see I feel like there's a big lead
between being artistic and being able to
translate a squiggly Ball created by
witches thousands of years ago well
no one would design a map you couldn't
read Apple so
so where do you call home these days
trying to open a star map with small
talk map stays here Sabine ignores this
request but to be fair Ahsoka didn't
give her much reason not to she could
have said that a powerful X Jedi his
Padawan and several assassin droids are
chasing that map better yet not for to
go with her to wherever she needs to
think more clearly so you can protect
her there are a million ways to solve
this bullsh drama tension
this is where it gets interesting over
promising I've been burned exactly one
season of the book above event too many
times to fall for that one in the last
500 years I've only known one student
who built the saber such as this isn't
every lightsaber unique I know the
colors aren't but the hilts are personal
to the Jedi that construct them so
couldn't you say the same thing about
every single lightsaber constructed ever
master and an apprentice okay now roll
commercials this highway is still empty
was it exclusively built to facilitate
sabine's urge to recklessly flip off the
nearest authority figure
snitches
off the ship when I explicitly told her
not to Anakin's Force ghost isn't in
this scene telling Ahsoka that Sabine is
payback for all the time she was a
little as a Padawan I don't
understand why things have to be so
difficult because TV and Hollywood execs
think audiences will implode unless
there's an inherent conflict to overcome
between Our Heroes all I'm saying is
just try it once if we do implode then
you can go right back to the formula
promise for you and I both also Bean
gives you the best chance of reading
that map that sure is a damning
indictment of the Republic scientists
and cryptographers isn't it
[Music]
Anakin never got to finish my training
oh pick me pick me I actually know who
Anakin is yes and I didn't even have to
rely on the loaded Paws or the suddenly
apparent dramatic shift in tone also her
master found it difficult to avoid
slaughtering women and children so maybe
Anakin's restraint doesn't make for the
best example here sometimes even the
right reasons have the wrong
consequences no consequences aren't
wrong or right consequences or
Consequences no your actions may have
unintended consequences but that's just
called owning your Ahsoka how do you
have all the sins back if this thing
suddenly stabbed her and summoned a
slurry of demons from hell and don't act
like sudden Hellraiser would make any
less sense than a cult of witches okay
let's talk about this map an order of
witches from thousands of years ago made
a map of the Galaxy hidden in a ball
turn that ball into a Rubik's sphere
buried that ball in a hole put the
answer to the puzzle on the floor above
that hole and then build a temple around
that all four why I mean clearly they
want to hide it from certain people but
the fact that they went to all this
effort in ahsokan Sabine managed to
figure it all out in a day or two shows
the witches managed to try far too hard
and not nearly hard enough also if this
thing was buried thousands of years ago
how can I know who thrawn is look that's
such a glaring error that I'm sure we'll
get answers as the series progresses but
I have a funny feeling it basically
comes down to the force did it and if
I'm wrong I'll write and perform an
apology song to the tune of the Star
Wars theme while juggling lightsabers
what is the point Droid if you get your
ass kicked like this you're a robot why
are you acting like that Bonk on the
Noggin stunned you we have a problem a
problem that Ahsoka predicted would
happen and yet decided to stay parked
out in the boonies instead of
immediately finding out where Sabine
lives and making sure she's safe if only
you had some kind of 500 year old armor
made of a metal that lightsabers can't
cut and weapons you were infinitely more
familiar with than lightsabers man if
only
[Music]
killing off a main character in the
first episode gutsy or at least that's
what I'd be thinking if I hadn't already
seen both kylo and the third sister get
run through with a lightsaber and
survive qui-gon's Force ghost is gonna
be pissed if yet another person survives
the lightsaber stabbing
oh
I'm calling it Bluff
that lost hand
killed me there were three things I love
in this world
Kylie Minogue
small dimples just above a woman's
buttocks beautiful features
and the fear in a man's eye who knows
I'm about to hurt him
just pick it up already what was this
place an ancient temple built by my
ancestors the night sisters of daphnea
you're a wizard Harry hello huyang still
in one piece say man you face well new
everything so
where do you call home these days this
ship serves me fine that's your home are
you too good for your home answer me you
know if Joey and Chandler walked in
right now we could make a fortune
Fortune